as you've seen in excruciating detail no
institution in American life has come
under more ferocious attack from the mob
than local police departments in
Minneapolis police are being abolished
entirely in Los Angeles in New York
their funding is being slashed
dramatically the cities around the
country monuments to the police are
being vandalized or ripped down the city
of Atlanta officer Garrett Rolfe faces
the death penalty for shooting a man
called Rashard Brooks after Rashard
Brooks stole his taser and fired it at
him so what a Republican officeholders
doing in the face of this unprecedented
attack on our laws and on Public Safety
itself well not a lot
few have stepped up to defend the police
from totally bogus accusations of quote
systemic racism some are repeating that
slur one republican though has gone
farther than that as we told you last
week Senator Mike Brown of Indiana has
introduced legislation to make it easier
for left-wing activists to sue police
officers we must do this senator Brown
explained in part because Rashard Brooks
his death was egregious I wanted to put
a template out there that protects law
enforcement from frivolous lawsuits but
holds the egregious departments and
individuals accountable in these
egregious you know instances of a George
Floyd a Rashard Brooks
a Brianna Taylor in case you suspect we
somehow selectively edited that clip
here's Republican senator Braun going
all the way in endorsing black lives
matter do you support the the black
lives matter movement I support that
movement because it's addressing and an
equity that has not been solved you know
from a grassroots level
after our segment on Thursday senator
Braun asked to come on this show to
detail his position of course we're
happy to have him senator Braun thanks
so much for coming on before I ask you
about qualified immunity in your
attempts to water it down I was very
surprised by that endorsement that you
gave on camera of black lives matter
black lives matter has of course called
for the murder of police officers why do
you support it and are there any other
race specific revolutionary movements
that you support so Tucker thanks for
having me on in the first place I know
when you clear them out and I like it
when somebody does challenge especially
something like this when you're talking
about changing something that's been
around for a while and Tucker I come
from Main Street your viewers are my
supporters and I've got one of the most
conservative know like that words now
that's true you'd have to check with
them just like I checked with the
Indiana State Police Indiana sheriffs
Association Fraternal Order Police spent
over an hour with them last week to make
sure I wasn't off base and here's where
I come from I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm
confused really quick hold on you're
you're off base in your support of black
lives matter your endorsement that you
just gave have you read their website or
are you in order of abolishing the
nuclear family what what do you support
exactly not at all what does that mean
oh I support anybody that does have a
grievance to be able to air it and
that's it that doesn't mean all lives
don't matter it just means that if you
think a certain sector the society has a
grievance it ought to be through
transparency and the willingness debated
and get it out there I'm gonna always go
on the merits of the particular case and
going back to what I learned last week
first of all law enforcement in Indiana
thought was talking about eliminating it
or drastically modifying it this was to
find that sweet spot to where they said
they are being unduly stigmatized
because of these events because in some
cases their own aren't held accountable
and when they knew that they basically
said we need to be in the discussion
look how we got rolled with Obamacare
when we refused I'm sorry I'm sorry
just showed tape of you senators saying
that we need to pull back we need to
make it easier to sue the police because
of quote egregious incidents like the
death of Rashard Brooks you just said
you wanted to speak about specifics do
you believe that he was killed unjustly
do you believe officer Roth deserves the
death penalty which he now faces what
did you mean by that
I believe you ought to have the ability
to just like when anyone's civil rights
would be violated that you've got access
to due process to have your case where
they do that but they do that right
qualified immunity homeland qualified
immunity has nothing to do with that
case he's been charged they have the
right to sue him under qualified
immunity as you know since you're
writing the change to the law so that's
irrelevant I'm asking about the case you
cited it do you believe that the officer
now facing the death penalty deserves to
face the death penalty and if you don't
tell us what he should have done I think
that that's gonna be determined by the
court and when it comes to so what do
you a hold on you cited it what do you
think of it you're the one who called it
egregious so why don't you tell us what
question where it should have done when
this man fired a taser at him what do
you think I think that you probably
should have had the judgment that in a
traffic stop like that you don't shoot
somebody in the back so if we keep doing
that so watch it I want you to explain I
think it's fair you're an officeholder
I don't normally press people like this
but it's not fair for you to filibuster
without answering my question which is
very simple the officer facing the death
penalty had a guy fire a weapon at him
what should he have done then probably
not have killed the guy and that'll come
what should he have done word you should
have probably not saying it's egregious
let him go you he do you think he was
gonna get away they were gonna find him
you tell me you tell me you're the one
judging the officer so maybe I could
explain why you're judging him Tucker
that all come out in the court process
and all I'm saying let me finish this if
we don't get better at it
for all of us on Main Street Democrats
are gonna spin it Chuck Schumer's
already decided he can make hey of this
in the election and we'll end up on the
short side of it again if you're wanting
to say
this Chuck Schumer controlled I thought
Republicans controlled the Senate and
your views from Chuck Schumer you gonna
say Chuck Schumer might criticize me
therefore I have to pass a law that
makes it easier to sue Tucker you know
you have to have 60 votes in the Senate
to get anything done you can check my
rat there got to change that when they
take over and even law enforcement in
Indiana thinks that in some of these
cases it's giving them a bad name in bad
apples ought to be there ought to be due
process there for the victim so what law
enforcement groups are endorsing your
bill they're not endorsing it but they
said it was a good kill to work from
well why aren't they endorsing it then
you've cited them twice as supporters of
this idea but they're not endorsing your
bill so they don't actually support it
so why are you bringing them up as
anything it's a good idea they think
it's a better idea that be in the
discussion then be outside of it but if
you care what they think why don't you
write something they'll endorse and that
doesn't necessarily mean we won't get
there that's not going to be done today
the Democrats now think they can win
with it in the election and that's why
we needed to be engaged now in a way
that would have kept it on so you need
to write a bill that law enforcement
won't endorse the country is burning not
because cops are burning it down but
because the mob is but you think the
morally culpable party is the police so
you're making it easier for left-wing
groups to sue them am I missing
something you are missing it but you're
trying to put words in my mouth
I don't think I'm not justify any of the
looting any of the rioting and if you
don't address the underlying issue do
you think it's gonna fix itself on its
own you think it's gonna get the
underlying issue is Ray chard Brooks
being shows it so you're telling me that
what's happening now is the result of
police behavior it's the police it's the
fault of the police that's what you're
saying because you don't say what
they're getting by with on the other
side is trying to generalize on the
specific and they'll get away with it if
we decide to do nothing that's just a
general disagreement and approach what
about Italy are you making it easier for
business owners to sue the mob for
burning their businesses down I haven't
noticed that bill coming out of the
Senate hey if we're not in the
discussion talk
we're going to be on the sidelines like
we are on so many issues as
conservatives because we fail to engage
and they run circles around this in the
end run you think you're going to keep
the Senate in the fall on this platform
I think we're going to keep the Senate
if we at least are willing to engage in
issues that are important to the
American public and that we don't always
stand on the sidelines until it's too
late it's more about yeah when you get
involved in the issues I don't think the
public supports you at all on this and
I'm with respect I just don't I think
law enforcement I think law enforcement
knows they need to have a better system
than what they got now because it's
stigmatizing them unduly okay senator
Brown thanks for joining us I appreciate
it you bet